so Samuel is working at Google project
zero on especially vulnerabilities in
web browsers and mobile devices he was
part of the team that discovered some of
the vulnerabilities that he will be
presenting in this talk today in detail
about the no user interaction
vulnerability that will be able to
remotely exploit and compromise iPhones
through iMessage please give Samuel
around one warm round of applause okay
thanks everyone welcome to my talk one
note before I start unfortunately I only
have one hour so I had to omit quite a
lot of details but there will be a blog
post coming out hopefully very soon that
has a lot more details but for this talk
I wanted to get everything in there and
leave out some details okay so this is
about iMessage in Syria some of it
applies or quite a lot actually applies
to other messengers but we'll focus on
iMessage so what is iMessage um yeah
it's a messaging service by Apple we've
heard about it in the previous talk a
bit as far as I know it is enabled by
default as soon as someone science into
an iPhone with their account which I
guess most people do because otherwise
you can't download apps interestingly
anyone can send messages through anyone
else so it's like SMS or phone calling
and then if you do this then it pops up
some notification so that you can see
that here on the on the right screen
shot which means that there must be some
kind of processing happening and so yeah
this is like default enabled 0 click
attack surface without the user doing
anything there stuff happening and then
on the very right we ensured you can see
that you can say receive messages from
unknown senders it just like says there
this sender's not in your contact list
but all the processing still happens
in terms of architecture this is roughly
how iMessage is structured it's not very
uh yeah anything too interesting I guess
you have Apple cloud servers and then
send and receive are connected to these
servers that's pretty much it
content is end-to-end encrypted which is
very good we heard this before also
interestingly this also means that Apple
can hardly detect or block these
exploits though because while they ice
encrypted right so that's an interesting
thing to note so what does an iMessage
exploit look like so in terms of
prerequisites really the attacker only
needs to know the phone number or the
email address which is the Apple account
the iPhone has to be in default
configuration so you can disable hi
message but that's not done by default
and the iPhone has to be connected to
the Internet and in terms of
prerequisites that's pretty much all you
need for this exploit to work so that's
quite a lot of iPhones the outcome is
attacker has full control over the
iPhone after a few minutes so I think it
takes like five to seven minutes maybe
and it is also possible with without any
visual indicators so there's no you
can't make it so there are no
notifications during this entire exploit
okay but before we get to exploiting of
course we need a vulnerability and for
that we need to do some reverse
engineering so I want to highlight a bit
how we started this or how we approach
this and I guess the first question
Europe you might be interested in is
what demon or what servers is handling
high messages so and one easy way to
figure this out is you can just make a
guess you look at your process list on
your Mac the Mac can also receive a
messages you like stop one of these
processes and then you see if I messages
are still delivered and if not then
probably you you follow the process
that's somewhat related to our messages
if we do this you find I am agent
already sounds
kind of related if you look at it it
also has an iMessage library that it's
loading so hey this seems very relevant
and then you can load this library in
Ida you see a screenshot top right and
you find a lot of handlers so for
example this message service session
handler incoming message
and then you can set a breakpoint there
and then at that point you can see these
messages as they come in
you can dump them display them look at
them change them and so this is a good
way to get started of course from there
you want to figure out how these
messages look like so yeah you can dump
them in there when they come in in the
handler on the right side you see how
these I messages look like more or less
on the wire
they are encoded as a P list which is an
Apple proprietary format yeah I think of
it like JSON or XML and I guess some
fields are self-explanatory so P is it's
the participants in this case is me
sending a message to another account I
own you have T which is the text content
of the message so hello 3063 you have a
version for some reason you also have an
XML or HTML ich feared which is probably
some legacy stuff it's being parsed this
XML but yeah the whole thing looks kind
of complex already I mean maybe you
would expect a simple string message to
just be a string in reality it's sending
this dictionary over the wire so let's
do some more attack surface enumeration
if you then like do more reverse
engineering reads the the code of the
handler you find two interesting keys
that can be present which is ATI and BP
and they can contain nskeyedarchiver
data which is another apple proprietary
serialization format it's quite complex
it it has
um quite a few bucks in the past on the
left side you see an example for such an
archive it's yeah it's being encoded in
a P list and then it's pretty much one
big array that has like every object has
an index in this area and here you can
see for example number seven is some
object and Estacada class and a shared
key dictionary and i think he one is an
instance of that class and so on so it's
quite powerful but really what this
means is that this SI realizes now 0
click attack surface because it's being
parsed on this path without any user
interaction yeah so I said it's by
complex it even supports things like
cyclic references so you can send an
object graph where a points to be and be
points back to a for whatever reason you
might want that naturally wrote a great
blog post where she describes is in more
detail what I have here is just an
example for the API how you use it
so this Objective C at the bottom if
you're not familiar with Objective C you
can think of these brackets as just
being method calls so this is doing in
the last line it's doing it's calling
the unarchive
object of classes message for this
nskeyedarchiver you can see you can pass
a wide list of classes so in this case
it will only decode dictionary strings
data etc so looks quite okay
interestingly if you dig deeper into
this this is not quite true because it
also allows all the subclasses to be
decoded so if you have an NS
something-something dictionary that
inherits from NS dictionary that that
can also be decoded here which is quite
unintuitive I think and this really
blows up the attack surface because now
you have not only these seven also
classes but you have like 50
okay so this is what we focused on when
me and Natalie were looking for
vulnerabilities it seemed like the most
complex thing we found we reported quite
a few vulnerabilities here you can see
it maybe a bit on the left the one I
decided to write an exploit for is this
1917 reported on July 29th and then
export sent on August lines yeah I
mostly I decided to use this one because
it seemed the most convenient
I do think many of the other ones could
be exploited in a similar way but not
quite as nice so would maybe take some
more heap manipulation etc so then
apples first push the mitigation quite
quickly which basically blocks this code
from being reached of a high message in
particular what they did is say exactly
no longer allows subclasses to be
decoded in iMessage so that's quite a
good mitigation of blocks of maybe 90%
of the attack surface here yeah so then
they fully fixed it on in iOS 13.2 but
again after August 26 this was only just
local attack surface okay so what is the
bug it's some yeah it's some
initialization problem during decoding
the vulnerable class is shared key
dictionary which again it's a subclass
of NS dictionary so it's allowed to be
decoded so let's take a look at that
so yeah shared key dictionary here's
some pseudocode and python it's a
dictionary so its purpose is to well
lookup keys to values or map keys to
values the lookup method is really
simple it just looks up an index in a
key set so every key dictionary has a
shared key set and then that index is
used to index into some area okay so
that's quite simple so the most of the
magic
happens in the shed he said and so what
that does is something like compute a
hash of the key I use that hash to index
into something called a rank table which
is an array of indices and then if that
index is valid so it's being bounced
checked against the number of keys then
it has found the the correct index and
if not it can recurse to another shared
key set so every shared key said can
have a sub shared key set and then it
repeats the same procedure so it already
looks kind of complex why does it have
why does it need this recursion I'm not
quite sure but it's there and so now we
look at how this goes wrong so this is
the init with coda which is the the
shared key set constructor used during
decoding with the ketonic IVA and it
looks pretty pretty solid at first it's
really just taking the values out of the
archive and then storing them as the
fields of this shared key set so I have
a I'm gonna go through the code here and
like single step two to highlight where
it goes wrong or what goes wrong here
what's wrong with this code so we start
with shared key set one which implies
there's going to be another one and at
the start it's all zero initialized it's
basically being allocated through car
lock so everything is zero then we
execute the first line okay so nam key
you see some interesting values coming
so far this is all fine note that you
can set num key at this point num key
can be anything because it's only being
validated in like three lines further
down right where it's making sure that
num key matches the the real length of
this array so this is fine but here it's
now recursing and it's decoding another
share key set so we start again we have
another shared key set all filled with
zeros
and we start from the top again nam ki
is one so this is this is a alleged
legitimate shaky said decoding a ranked
table and here we are making a circle so
for shared key said to we pretend that
it's a sub T set is shaky said one and
this actually works
so the nskeyedarchiver has special
handling to handle this correctly so it
does not create a third object and it
makes the cycle and we're good to go
okay next the decodes the keys area so
this is fine shakey set fire to is seems
legitimate so far and now it's I'm doing
some sanity checking where it's trying
where it's making sure that this shared
key set can look up every key and so it
does this for the only key it has key
one now at this point it's again
remember it's going like it's hashing
the key going into rank table it takes
out 42 which is bigger than num key so
in this case it that this lookup here
has failed and now it's recursing to
share key set 1 right this was the logic
and at this point it's taking out this
hex 4 1 4 1 4 1 4 1 as index compares it
against hex ffffff and that's fine and
now it's accessing another point my
pointer which is keys the keys area is
to deny pointer + well 4 1 4 1 4 1 4 1
times 8 so at this point it's crashing
it's accessing invalid memory precisely
because in this situation shared key
said one hasn't been validated yet ok so
that's the back we're going to exploit I
have these check points just to think
where we are so we now have a
vulnerability in this MSR are kind of an
API we can trigger it through try
message
so what exploit primitive do we have
let's take a look again at the lookup
function which we saw before so here
where it's bold this is where we crash
keys is now a pointer index is fully
controlled so we can access like null
pointer plus offset and then what
happens is the result of this memory
access is going to be used as some
objective-c object so this is all
objective-c in reality it's doing some
comparison which means it does something
like it calls a method called is in a
string for example and then also
eventually it calls dialogue which is
the destructor so yeah we we have we can
like this thing it reads from whatever
it will treat it as an objective-c
object called some message on it and
that's our exploitation primitive okay
so here we are how do we exploit this so
the rough idea for exploiting such
vulnerabilities looks like this you want
to have some fake objective-c object
somewhere in memory that you're
referencing so again we have an we can
access an arbitrary absolute address we
want some fake objective-c object there
every objective-c object has a pointer
to its class and then the class has
something called a method table which
basically has two function pointers to
these methods right and so if we fake
this entire data structure thing so the
fake the fake object and the fake class
then as soon as the process called some
method on our fake thing we get code
execution so we get control over the
instruction pointer
and then it's game over so that's going
to going to be our goal for this exploit
so here we have two different types of
addresses on the left side we have heap
addresses or data really and on the
right side in this nsstring thing we
need library addresses or code addresses
simply because on iOS you can't have you
can't have writable code regions so we
have to necessarily reuse existing code
to something like Rob also so we need to
know where libraries are mapped for this
right and this is exactly the problem
we're gonna face now
because there's something called a SLR
address space layout randomization and
what it does is it will randomize this
entire address space so on the left side
you can see how a process looks like how
the virtual memory of a process looks
like before a SLR and there everything
is always mapped at the same address so
if you start the same address twice on
different phones maybe even without a
SLR the same library is at the same
address the heap is always at the same
address stack everything is the same and
so this would be really simple to
exploit now because well everything is
the same with a SLR everything is
shifted and now all the addresses are
randomized and we don't really know
where anything is and so that makes it
harder to exploit this so we need an egg
SLR bypass is what this means we're
gonna divide it into two parts so the
heap addresses we get them from in a
different way than the library addresses
so let's see how we get heap addresses
it's really simple bit honestly it's you
what you can do is heap spraying which
is an old technique I think 15 years old
maybe and it does still work today
the ideas that you simply allocate lots
of memory so if you look at this code
snippet on the right which you can use
to test that what it does it it is it
allocates 256 megabytes of memory on the
heap with malloc and then afterwards
there's one address or there's many
addresses but in this case I'm using
this hex one one seven zeroes
where you will find your data at okay so
just spraying 256 megabytes lets you put
control data header control address
which is enough further for this first
part of the exploit the remaining quest
was how can you keep spray over iMessage
that's a bit more complicated
but it is possible because
nskeyedarchiver is great and it lets you
do all sorts of weird stuff which you
can abuse for heaps brain so yeah blog
posts will have more details okay so we
have these the heap addresses we have
them we need the library addresses let's
go back to the virtual memory space on
iOS and also on Mac OS the libraries so
maybe in this case those three libraries
but in reality it's like hundreds of
system libraries they are all drilling
into one gigantic binary blob which is
called the dy LD share cache the idea is
that this speeds up like loading times
because all the interdependencies
between libraries are resolved pretty
much at compile time but yeah so we have
this gigantic binary blob and it has
everything we need so it has all the
code it has all the Rob gadgets and it
has all the objective-c classes so we
have to know where this d-y are the
shared cache is mapped if you dig into
that a bit or if you look at the
documentation or the the binaries you
can find out that it is going to be
mapped always between two these two
addresses
so between hex one eight seven zero and
hex - eight seven zero which leaves only
a 4 gigabyte region so it's only being
mapped in these four gigabytes and then
the randomization granularity is also
hex 4000 because iOS uses large pages so
it can only randomize like here on which
page granularity and that page
regularity is hex 4000 but really what's
most interesting is that on the same
device the dyd shared caches only
randomized once per boot ok so if you if
you have two different processes on the
same device the shared cache is at the
same virtual address and if you have one
process and it crashes and you have
another one and so on like the shared
cache is always going to be at the same
address and that makes it really
interesting
and also it's one gigabyte in size it's
gigantic
so it's not too hard to find in this
four gigabyte region right so this is
what our our task has boiled down to at
this point we have this this address
range we have the shared cache and all
we need to know now is what is this
offset so let's make a sort experiment
let's say we had an Oracle which would
tell us which we could give an address
and it would tell us if this address is
mapped in the remote process okay if we
have this it suddenly becomes really
easy to solve this problem because then
all you have to do is you go in one
gigabyte steps the the size of the
shared cache between these two addresses
and then at some point you find a valid
address so maybe here after three steps
you find a valid address and then from
there you just do a binary search right
because you know that somewhere between
the green and the second red arrow the
shared cache starts so you can do a
binary search and you find the the start
address in logarithmic time in a few
seconds minutes whatever
so obviously the question is well how
where would we get this Oracle from this
seems kind of weird
so let's look it receives message
receipts so I message like many other
messengers I think pretty much all of
them that I know send receipts for
different things my message in
particular has delivery receipts and
read receipts delivery receipt says the
device received the message we'd
received means the user actually looked
open the app looked at the message you
can turn of read receives but as far as
I know you cannot turn off delivery
receipts and so here on the left you see
a screenshot three different messages
were sent and they have three different
states the first message was marked as
red which means
got a delivery received and a REIT
received the second message is marked as
delivered so it only got a delivery
received and the third message doesn't
have anything so it hasn't received any
receipts okay so why is it useful here
on the left is some pseudocode of I am
agents handling of or like yeah how it
handles messages and when it sends these
receipts and so you can see that it
first like parses the the penis that's
coming in and it's then doing this NS on
archiving some at some later time and
this is exactly why our bug would
trigger during NS on archive and only
then does it send a delivery received
right so what that means is if during
our during our NS on archive if we can
trigger the bug and cause a crash then
we have somewhat of a 1-bit site chatter
right because if we cause a crash then
we won't see a delivery received and if
we don't cause a crash then we see a
delivery received so it's a one bit of
information and this is going to be our
Oracle right so ideally you have a
vulnerability that gives you this
perfect Oracle of is an address mapped
or not so crash if it is not mapped
don't crash if it is map in reality you
probably will not get this perfect
Oracle from your buck on the left side
you see the real Oracle function for
this vulnerability which is well it has
to be mapped okay but then it's also
using the value that it's reading and so
it will only not crash if the value is
either 0 or or if it has the most
significant bit set this is some like
pointer tagging stuff or if it's unreal
if it's a real legitimate pointer to an
objective-c object so this Oracle
function is a bit more complex but the
similar idea still works so you can
still infer the like to some something
like a binary search and infer the
shared cash start address in logarithmic
time
right and so it only takes maybe five
minutes or so to do this but yeah for
this for this part again I have to refer
to the blog post which will cover how
this works okay so this is the summary
of the remote is on our bypass two
phases this like linear scan where just
like scanning sending these payloads and
checking if if it gets the received back
and the first time it gets a receive
back it knows okay this address is valid
I now found an address that is within
the shared cache and at that point it
starts just like searching phase which
in logarithmic time figures out the
exact precise starting address okay so
there's a few common questions about
this that I want to briefly go into the
first maybe obvious question is can you
really just crash this agent like
20-plus times and the answer is yes
there's no no indicator or anything that
the user would would see that this demon
crashes the only thing you can do is you
can go into like settings privacy
something something crash log something
and then you can see these crash logs
second question is you can I think by
default the iPhone is configured to send
crash logs to the vendor to Apple so
isn't that a problem so I think I looked
at this briefly what I stumbled across
was that it seems that iOS collects at
most 25 crash logs per service it's not
that this is not designed to be like a
security feature right so this makes
sense
but what that means is that an attacker
can use some kind of well resourcing sha
exhaustion back to crash this demon
maybe 25 times first and then only start
the exploit and then no trace of the
expert will be sent over third question
is whether this can be fixed by simply
sending the delivery received very early
on I think this is this was my first
suggestion to Apple
- like just well sent this delivery
receipt right at the start
eventually I figured out it doesn't
really work because you can still make
some kind of timing side china because
when when a demon crashes multiple times
it's subject to some penalty and it will
only restart like a few seconds or even
minutes later so from that from the
timing of getting a delivery receipt you
can then still basically get this Oracle
all right so it doesn't really work by
just sending it earlier I'll go into
some other ideas that might work later
ok so at this point I'm starting the
demo the demo is two parts let's see
where it is right so I have this iPhone
here and you can with QuickTime just the
screen is mirror to the projector so
this iPhone is it's a tennis so it's
from last year it's on 12.4 which is the
last bootable version so that's like
half a year old at this point and what
else so there's no no no existing chance
open okay and let's see so yeah I hope
the Wi-Fi works what you can see here is
the way the exploit works it's it's
hooking with fried are in - do we get
delivery sleeved yeah okay cool it works
so yeah it's popping up these messages
the way the export works it it's hooking
the messages have on Mac OS with Friday
and then it's sending these like
specific marker messages like inject
Atia
and then the fried our hook replaces
this message with like the current
payload right and now it's testing these
addresses it's not too slow I guess
yeah and popping up some nice messages
okay it already found okay so this is
already the end of the first stage so
that was quite fast
it found a valid address in this like
first probing step and now it has 21,000
candidates for the shared cash base
I know it's doing this kind of binary
search thing to have that in every step
okay now it only has 10,000 left and so
it's quite fast and quite efficient okay
while this runs let's continue so this
is where we are we can now create fake
objects we have all the addresses we
need it's like this one one seven zero
is where we can place our stuff and then
we will gain control over the program
counter and from there its standard
stuff right it's what you would do in
all of these exploits you pivot maybe to
the stack you do return oriented
programming and then you can run your
code and you've succeeded now at this
point there is another thing coming in
point of syndication is a new security
feature that Apple designed and
implemented first in the 10s so this
device from 2018 and the idea is that
you can now so this needs if you support
the idea is that you can now store a
cryptographic signature in the top bits
of a pointer okay so here on the very
left side you have a long pointer so the
top bits are zero because the way the
address space works now there's a set of
instructions that sign a pointer and
they will take them maybe they can take
a context or not but they use some key
that's not in memory that's in a
register computer a signature of this
pointer and store the signature in the
top bits and that's what you see on the
right side the green things that's the
signature and now before using this
pointer the code will now send to
by by running another instruction and
this instruction if the verification
fails it will basically Club at this
point or make it invalid and then the
following instruction will just crash
right so here this is the function
called the B air branch and Link
instruction this is doing a function
call to a function pointer but first
it's authenticating this pointer and if
this authentication step fails then the
process will crash right there what this
means for an attacker is that more or
less Rob is dead because Rob involves
faking a bunch of function pointer like
well code pointers really that point in
the middle of existing code so this is
no longer possible because an attacker
cannot generate these signatures so this
is where our exploit breaks right the
registering where we have a fake
objective-c class with our own function
pointer this does no longer work because
we cannot compute these signatures so
what do we do one thing that's still
possible and it's even documented in the
documentation is that this class pointer
in the object was also called the ISO
pointer it's not protected by PAC in any
way which means we can fake instances of
legitimate existing classes right so in
this case here we can have a fake object
that points to a real class that has
real legitimate assigned method pointers
so this step works and with this we can
now get existing methods called like out
of place and like kind of manipulator
control so and these existing methods
are basically now gadgets so if you want
to think about it that way
ok so what can we do with this one very
interesting method we can get call this
dialog the destructor so I think in
quite a few may be most of the
objective-c rotation scenarios you can
probably get a
dialogue method called now what you do
is you just enumerate all the
destructors in the shared cache there's
tons of them I sing 50,000 and you can
get any of those called and then one of
them or a few of them are really
interesting because they call this
invoke method which is part of the NS
invocation object or class and an NS
invocation is basically a bound function
so it has a target object the message to
be called and all the arguments and as
soon as you call invoke on this NS
invocation it does this method call with
fully controlled arguments right so what
that means is with this destructor we
can now make a fake object with a fake
NS invocation that has any method call
we would like to perform and then it's
going to do that because it run hits
running this invoke here again you see
this shield here which I put in place
for things that Apple has hardened since
we sent them to exploit so what they did
so far is a hardened NS invocation and
it's now no longer easily possible to
abuse it in this way but yeah so for us
we can now run arbitrary Objective C
methods was controlled arguments
what about sandboxing if you do some
more reverse engineering and figure out
what service is playing into iMessage
this is what you end up was on the right
side so you have a number of services
most of them are sandbox if you had the
red board I mean there's the sandbox
interestingly springboard also does some
NS on archiver stuff so it's decoding
the VP key so it's also it could also
trigger our vulnerability and spring
what is not signpost so it's the main UI
process it's basically what's handling
there like showing the the welcome
screen and so on
and so what that means is well we can
just target springboard and then we get
code execution outside of the sandbox so
we don't actually need to worry too much
about the sandbox as of IRS 13 this is
fixed and
this key is now decoded in the sandbox
cool so we can execute objective-c
methods outside of the sandbox we can
with that access user data activate
camera microphone etc this is all
possible through Objective C quite
easily but of course we don't care about
that what we want is a calculator and
this is also quite easy with one
objective-c call a UI application launch
application blah blah blah and so let's
see if this works go back to the demo so
where we had so the the ASR bypass
transform you can nicely see that it
roughly half the candidates in every
round or with every message it had to
send it ended up with just one message
I'll just yeah well it was just one
candidate at the end and that is the
shared cash base in this case hex 1/8 a
6-0 eight zero zero zero
now it's preparing the heap spray this
is all kind of hacked together I think
if you wanted to do this properly I know
so for one you can send the whole heap
spray in one message I'm just lazy it's
also probably way too big
another thing is I think you would
probably know Target springboard in
reality just because bring mode is very
sensitive so if you crash it you get
this respring and the like UI every
starts so I think in reality you would
probably target I am agent and then
chain a sandbox escape because well this
this bug would also get your of the
sandbox so looks should be doable ok so
I think the last message arrived it's
freezing here for a couple seconds I
don't actually know why I never bother
but it does work
[Applause]
yeah so that there was a demo it's it
kind of naturally reliable this exploit
because there's no not much of heat
manipulation involved except this one
heap spray which is controllable okay
so what's left mmm I think one more
thing you can do is you can attack the
kernel if you want that you have to deal
with two problems here one is code
signing you cannot execute unsigned
count on iOS and then the standard
workaround for that is you abuse JIT
pages in Safari but we're not in Safari
or we're not in web content so we don't
have JIT pages what I did here is I
basically pivoted into JavaScript core
which is the the J's library you can use
it from from any app also and then I'm
just bridging this calls into JavaScript
and then implementing the kernel exploit
in JavaScript this does not require any
more vulnerabilities so you do not need
a JavaScript core but to do this and the
idea is very similar to Pony is maybe
some of you know about that it's a
library I think initially developed for
edge because they did something similar
with like JIT page gardening's so what I
decided to do is take sock puppet from
net or CVE 2019 8605 which works on this
version it works on 12.4 this is the
trigger for it and I only ported the
trigger I didn't bother reimplemented
the entire exploit so yeah this is the
trigger it will cause a kernel panic
it's quite short which is nice so if you
want to run this from JavaScript really
there's only three things you care about
right so the first one is you need to
syscalls
okay so highlight it here there is like
four or so different search calls here
not a lot and you just have to be able
to call them from JavaScript the other
thing is you need constants right so
eye-fi nets
extreme these are all integer constants
so this is really easy right you just
need to look up what these values and
not-being and then the last thing is you
need some data structures so in this
case I'd needs this has o NP extension
thing it needs some integer value to
pass point us two and so on yeah and
then this is kind of the magic that
happens you take sockpuppet dot c
extract this is called etc there's one
Objective C message you can call which
is very convenient which gives you DL
sim what this lets you do it it lets you
get native C function pointers that are
signed right because so far we can only
call Objective C methods but we need to
be able to call sis calls or at least
the C wrapper functions so with this
diem method thing we can get signed
pointers to C functions then we need to
be able to pivot into JavaScript core
which is also really easy with one
method call the J's context evaluate
script we need to mess around with
memory a bit like corrupt some objects
from outside corrupt some area buffers
in JavaScript get read right kind of
standard browser exploitation tricks I
guess but yeah so if you do this what
you end up with is sockpuppet ojs looks
very similar you can see a bit of my
JavaScript API that lets you allocate
memory buffers I read and write memory
have some integer constants and yeah
apart from that it doesn't really look
much different from the initial trigger
and so this can now be served over
well-staged on to the high message
exploit building on top of this
objective-c method called primitive and
I guess at least in Syria didn't fully
implement it this should be able to just
run a kernel exploit and well fully
compromise the device without any
interaction in probably less than 10
minutes
okay so this was the first part how does
how does this exploit work what I have
now is the number of suggestions how to
make this harder how to improve things
so one of the first things that that is
really critical for this exploit is the
hairs and our bypass which relies on a
couple of things and I think a lot of
this is our bypass also works on other
platforms so Android has a very similar
problem with like mappings being at the
same address the cross processes and
other messengers have these like
receives and so on so I think a lot of
this applies not just to Apple but to
Android and to other messengers but okay
what is the first point
so we ksl are but this is basically the
heap spraying which is just too easy or
there shouldn't be so easy in terms of
theoretical area so now you can see it
may be sketched here on the right
in theory I guess I could be much
stronger much more randomized in reality
it's just like the small red bar so it
really it should just have much more
entropy to make keep spraying not viable
anymore
the next problem with a SLRs is per boot
stuff again at the bottom you can see it
right so you have three different
processes the shared cache is always at
the same headers similar problems on
other platforms I mentioned that this is
probably hard to fix because by this
point a lot of quite a lot relies on
this and it's it would be a big
performance hit to change this but maybe
some server engineers can figure out how
to do it better
the third part here is the delivery
receipts which interestingly they can
give you the side Channel this one bit
information side Channel and this can be
enough to break SR and as I've mentioned
before I think a lot of other messengers
have this same problem what what might
work is to either will remove these
receipts sure
or maybe send them from a different
process so you can't do this timing
thing or even from the server I think if
you send them if the server already
sends the delivery receipt it's a bit of
cheating but at least this attack
doesn't work
they send boxing another thing it's
probably obvious right so the everything
that's on 0 click attack surface should
be sent boxed as much as possible of
course - you know require the attacker
to do another fully exploit after
getting code execution but sandboxing
can also complicate information leaks so
Natalie had this other high message bug
CVE something 8 6 4 6 there's a blog
post about this one it basically lets
you or she was able to send to cause a
springboard to send HTTP requests to
some server and those would contain
pictures data whatever
if springboard would have been sandbox
to not allow Network activities this
would have been much harder so
sandboxing is not necessarily just about
this second breakout what I do want to
say about sandboxing that it shouldn't
be relied on so I think this remote
attack surface is pretty hard and it's
not unlikely that it's actually harder
than the sandboxing attack surface and
also on top of that this park
nskeyedarchiver but it would also get
you out of the sandbox because the same
api is used locally for IPC so there's
that yeah this would be nice if the 0
click attack surface code would be
open-source would would have been nice
for us I would have been easier to audit
maybe someday another feature that I
would like to see or another theme is
reduced 0 click attack surface make it
one click at least one click attack
surface right so before and here you you
could see that an unknown sender can
send any messages it would be nice if
there would be some pop-ups it's like
wow
do you actually want to accept messages
3my lets you block unknown senders I
think that's a cool feature
Sariah there's more work to be done here
also this restarting service problem I
think it it could get bigger even so
here we had pretty much unlimited tries
for the ASL heart bypass it's probably
going to become even more relevant with
memory tagging which we could can also
be defeated if you have many tries so
yeah I guess if some process or some
like critical daemon crashes 10 times
maybe not we started I don't know it's
it's gonna need some more syncing right
you don't want to denial-of-service the
user by just not restarting this demon
that crashed for some unrelated reason
but yeah this would be a very good idea
to have some kind of limit here okay
conclusion um so yeah 0 click exploit
they are saying they do exist it is
possible to to exploit singer memory
corruption bugs on this surface with you
know without separate info leaks
despite all the mitigations we have
however I do think by turning the right
knobs this could be made much harder so
I gave some suggestions here and yeah we
need more attack surface reduction
especially on this 0 click surface but I
think there is progress being made and
with that thanks for your attention and
I think we have time for questions thank
you
we do have time for questions and if
you're in the room you should line up at
the microphones and then we might also
have questions from the internet one
quick reminder is that all fun things
that what they work with explicit
consent that includes photos so the
photo policy of the CCC is that if you
take a photo you need to have explicit
consent by the people in the frame so
remember don't do any long shots into
the crowd because you want to have the
consent of everybody there good we have
the first question from the internet the
internet wants to know did Apple give
you some kind of a reward and was it in
your iPhone I know we did not get any
kind of reward but we also didn't ask
for it so there is that if I didn't know
I didn't get a new iPhone I'm still
using mine which is it yeah I mean this
is a 10 s right so current current
hardware models can be defeated with
this if that is a question
good we have a question for microphone
number three hello just a question I did
not truly understand how the fix with
server or having another process sending
the delivery message will fix the
problem because if it does work if
you're in the right addresses the thing
just will work make the server or other
processes and the delivery message and
if it crashes it doesn't do anything so
so the idea would be in this case I'm
like sending this one message that would
crash and then hi as I get a delivery
receipt I don't if the server already
sends the delivery we see before it
actually like gives the message to the
client or to the receiver then I would
always see a delivery received and I
wouldn't be able to figure out if my
message caused the crash or not alright
so that's the idea behind maybe sending
it on the server side if that makes
sense yeah but in this case if legit
legit people send a message and it
doesn't reach the yeah yeah hits a hack
right so it's not perfect I mean the
server could only sense it and this
delivery received once it like send it
out over TCP and maybe got a TCP arc or
whatever which happens in the corner but
it's a heck in any case yeah like it's a
trade off we have a question for
microphone number two hello okay thanks
for the talk two questions first it's
always 10 also a potential candidate for
this back and second can you distinguish
multiple devices with your address based
randomization detection hmm so your host
or Mac OS is affected just the same I
think this specific exploit would
directly work because address spaces
like looks a bit different but I think
you could make it work
and it's affected in terms of multiple
devices so I haven't played around with
that I could imagine that it is possible
to somehow figure out that there are
multiple devices or that you know which
device just crashed but I haven't
investigated that's the answer
thanks we'll have time for more
questions there is a question from
microphone number one hi thanks for the
talk a quick question you said that
exploitation could be made without
having any notification how would that
be made yes I briefly looked into how it
could work well so for one you can like
take out parts of the message so that
it's a it's parsing later on in the
processing and then it will just be like
thrown away because it says well this is
garbage the other thing is of course
once you get with the like very last
message where you get code execution you
can prevent it from showing a message
like a notification because that happens
afterwards until you get the code
execution you can't remove them it so
usually the first message does no but
you can do the other the other thing
like make it make the message look bad
bad enough that like later pausing
stages will throw them away
Thanks yep good we have a couple of more
questions remember if you don't feel
comfortable lining up behind the
microphones you can ask through the
signal angel through the internet
microphone number 4 please
yes hi hi Samuel um I was cute you have
some suggestions about reducing the
attack surface are there any suggestions
that you'd make to save like Apple or
Google you know in terms of what they
can see you mentioned logging a little
bit earlier yeah so I send up pretty
much this list with the exploit I sent
to help and I think the blog post will
have a bit more but yeah so I I told
them the same things yeah if that's your
question
then I get it right
yes I mean I maybe I misunderstood a
little bit but I think I suppose that
some of these reductions of the tax
surface seem to be in terms of like
what's happening on the device yeah on
whereas I'm wondering in terms of
monitoring so being able to catch
something like this in progress right
right so this is gonna be really hard
because of end-to-end encryption so the
server just sees like encrypted garbage
and has no way of knowing it's this an
image is there's a text this is an
exploit so on the server I don't think
you can do much there I think it's gonna
it's gonna have to be on the device we
have a question from the internet how do
you approach attack surface mapping well
reverse engineering playing around
looking at this message format in this
case of what was somewhat obvious what
attack surface was right so figure out
which keys of this message are being
processed in some way make a note decide
which one looks most complex go for that
first that's what we did we have a
question from microphone number two
please hi how long did you and your
colleague research to get the export
running so the the vulnerability finding
thing was Natalie
I think we spend maybe three months
finding that the exploit so I had a
rough idea how I wanted to how I would
approach this exploit so I think at the
end it took me maybe a week to finish it
but I had thought about doing that for
like while looking whilst looking for
vulnerabilities and those two to three
months we have another question from
microphone number three it's there the
threat that an attacked iPhone would
itself turn into a tech up by they
exploit sure yeah you can do that I mean
you have full control right so you have
access to the contacts list
and you can send out hi messages the
question is if it's necessary right I
mean you can also send messages from you
don't really need them the iPhone to
send the messages but I think in theory
yes that's possible
do we have more questions from the
internet does the phones they compromise
after a start so there's no persistence
exploit here no you will need another
exploit little I loaded a talk I think
just an hour ago about persistence so
you would need to chain this
with what for example they exploit that
he showed and if you have questions in
the room please line up behind the
microphones do we have more questions
from the internet yes
so you've achieved the most novel bug
ever found to be fine in iOS what's the
next big thing you'll be looking at good
question oh I don't really know myself
but I'm going to stay probably around 4
0 click it takes office reduction for a
bit more looks like we don't have any
brave people asking questions in the
room does the internet have more courage
how long does discover an explanation
and development take and how much does
the team work improve the process and
development time ok so how long does
this exploitation process work is that
the first question yes yeah I mean this
is generally your heart sink two hands I
write this like years of hacking around
and learning how to do this stuff etc
that you have to take into account but
as I said I had a rough idea how this
exploit would look like so then we leave
implementing is what like one or two
weeks the the initial part of reverse
engineering iMessage reverse engineering
design s ketonic I was saying this took
forever this took many months and it was
also very necessary for high speed
writing right so a lot of the expert
primitives I use they also
abuse the hennas ketonic I have a thing
we have time for perhaps two quick
questions for micro on phone number four
please
super I'm not super familiar with iOS is
virtual memory addresses but you should
to heap regions when you showed the
picture of it and I'm wondering why are
there two heap regions okay yeah there's
only a minor detail but I think there's
one heap region initially like below the
shared cache and once that is full
it just makes another one above it so
it's really just like if the one gets
used all gets gets used up it makes
another one and that's going to be like
above the shared cache I think that's
the picture you're referring to yeah
thank you and unfortunately we are out
of time so the person that might have
for number one please come up to the
stage afterwards and past you can grab a
talk so please give round warm I can't
say this
[Applause]
[Music]
you